oui oui je vais tirer et jouer je vais
éteindre également mon portable et je
vais faire ce qu'on fait toujours ce
genre de choses de ce soir sur la veste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ben c'est évidemment trois choses au
nord surprise et enthousiasme
[Musique]
d'abord le sujet est évidemment des
plans des dés début de chapitre voir
comment tout cela peut ça j'en sais et
puis finalement la thématique est
d'apporter le sujet et le plan de viale
index il n'ya plus qu'à écrire le livre
[Musique]
le plus gros mystère c'est certainement
dû par le début comment cet homme est
arrivé au pouvoir dans une situation qui
n'était pas
la même que dans d'autres dictatures
donc ceux d'été il n'y avait rien
d'inévitable et la première chute en 43
en juillet 43 qui vous être pour lui la
sortie de deux des jeux politiques et
finalement ça n'a pas marché
[Musique]
les deux sont des personnages
intéressants mais un défaut pour un
biographe à défaut qui est leur qualité
ce qu'est ce qu'ils sont vivants je
crois à l'excellente santé un biographe
doit se pencher en tout cas ces faits de
l'histoire sur un sujet qui un temps au
début et à la fin ce n'est pas le cas
des deux éminentes personnalités que
vous mentionnez
[Musique]
c'est un vaste débat franco français
mais qui intéresse toute l'europe dans
la mesure où nous avons tous connu dans
l'europe continentale des régimes
croupion des régimes qui étaient
imposées par l'allemagne nazie
victorieuse évidemment c'est une
question de sensibilité de bilan
extrêmement difficile à faire d'un cas à
l'autre et j'ajouterais d'une période à
l'autre 40 n'est pas 41 qui n'est pas 42
et assez de suite
[Musique]